Jamie starts us off in Oklahoma City
this hour hi Jamie how are you I am
doing well how are you Dave better than
I deserve what up what's up I thought I
really wanted the first time I first to
ever call you would be Fredette free
screen but unfortunately not the case I
wanted to ask you my in-laws have been
unemployed since last February and don't
have enough money for rent this month
and they have zero plans for what
they're going to do because they don't
have enough money to move they'll have
enough money to pay rent
so my husband and I are kind of
struggling to determine do we step in
and kind of move them up with us there
in Texas or in Oklahoma and put them in
an apartment get them utilities get them
kind of settled or do we just kind of I
mean in that case we want to put rules
on our money because we're not going to
just throw good money after bad and I
guess we're kind of wondering do we kind
of leave them homeless or do we how much
how much $1,200 a month and they've not
even been doing part-time jobs you know
no his dad worked for about a month on a
contract job but ended February 7th and
that was only for about 30 days why are
they not doing anything
well he's what we know is he doesn't
want to get a job because he's afraid
that when he gets up for being able to
reapply for unemployment in March that
he won't be able to get it because he's
working I guess we don't really know
there's no answer to that
jobs generally do mess up the
unemployment what we will review so I
don't want to settle for like a job at
Target or delivering pizzas or something
like that if he can go he's an
industrial engineer by trade but but it
kind of keeps us kind of part of where
we're at is we were on baby step 2 for
$75,000 down out of our hundred and
seven thousand we started with and if we
step in and do this we were going to be
debt-free and
member but now I mean what what is your
household income um
about 120 KS what wider why is his wife
not working a guy um she she hasn't
worked in years she's partially disabled
I see okay so um their long-term game
plan is to not work
I'm so confused as to how this is going
to work out I don't I mean I'm not you
know you're not you're presenting them
as people who haven't gotten a job and
won't get a job and how's this gonna
work I'm soaked I mean maybe I'm missing
something
he's been applying for a job up here in
Oklahoma City since November and he just
had another interview with them last
Friday but I mean that's last November -
now so we don't know if he'll get it um
that's one job he's kind of just waiting
yeah and but I mean if he doesn't get
that job what is his plan I don't think
they have one
I mean I've sent them the emails on this
is Texas Housing Authority you know
emergency help with rent you clearly
need something but I mean there's I've
come to you and ask you for help
um not yet she's sounds a little
passive-aggressive and calls and just
cries because we have no plan we don't
know what we're gonna do
but then tells us that we make too much
money for them to be homeless so maybe
you need a plan mom like really but than
before and this isn't the first time
either my husband graduated from college
and literally moved two parents in with
him
I mean paid so homes paid still pay well
here's the first thing um you're not
going to be pleased doing a lot I can
hear that from the way you're talking
this through because you think that
they're being lazy yeah either one of us
are happy but we do have to feel like we
make too much money for them to be I
don't I don't
think you have too much money for they
would be homeless I'm I'm kind of good
with it really so because they won't
frickin work so I'm kind of good with
them you know reaping some consequences
from their stupid but decisions and
they're sitting at home watching Oprah
reruns instead of I'm too good to
deliver pizza I'm too good to work at
Target I'm not I've done all of these
things I've shoveled crap out of houses
that was undescribable and so I mean
I've cut grass I've wacked briars I've
done you know and so I I don't get it
somewhere there's somebody needs a lawn
cut there's a somebody needs a dog walk
there's somebody some Leafs blown you
know that leaves a blown there there's I
mean this is ridiculous that these
people lose their house because this
guy's too proud to do something he's too
you know this freakin entitlement stuff
just drives me bananas
so I'm sorry I'm venting now but I mean
I I just because it's not fair that they
expect you guys it's like the whole
culture now well you make so much money
you should share some of it why because
I work and you freakin won't I don't get
that culturally I don't get it and then
a family I don't get it and so if I'm
going to do something here it's going to
bring an end to this crap meaning we're
going to put up a certain amount of
money you don't sign the lease under any
circumstances but if you put up a
certain amount of money to help them do
something here or there
then they need it then there has to be
some it's going to be a real
uncomfortable conversation if I'm their
coach you know I mean can we give an
example if it wasn't you it let's say I
was working as an elder in a church and
these people came in for help let me
tell you what I would require of them I
would require they go through Financial
Peace University I would require they
attend prayer with our prayer team I
would require that he takes six jobs of
any kind in the next two weeks and then
I would help them but I'm not going to
participate in their lack of ambition
I'm not going to participate in their in
their delusion that that that somehow
someone else is supposed to take care of
them because at 50 something years old
they won't get off their home
but sand do it now that I know that
sounds mean but it's not really mean
because they've got a pattern of their
life that has hurt them in the way they
behave and that pattern has to be broken
if you're going to invest in an invest
in something that breaks the pattern and
then you can feel good about it and let
me just tell you what will happen by the
way is this this woman she's not only
passive aggressive she's a travel agent
for guilt trips absolutely she knows how
to dial it up and so she woman had told
me that she wished I would die if she
could have her son back because I
changed him by putting him on your plan
and making him realize but when was
another way to live life
when was this we we got married oh when
she told me that about it I don't know a
year ago okay no money no money no money
that's it people that wish I die I don't
give money to carry no no I you yeah
you're right I changed your son he's no
longer a wuss no no money deal with it
you don't wish I die and then I give you
money that's the end of that in the
discussion this is the Dave Ramsey show
you